hello everybody and welcome to an
exciting mini-series in socket
programming with Python three sockets
are pretty complex or the candy complex
but they're actually not not that
confusing once you're comfortable with
them part of what makes socket
programming or learning how to do sucker
programming difficult is there's kind of
a lack of documentation for Python in
general and socket programming see I
guess by lack of documentation I should
define what that means really and
there's plenty of documentation for how
to use Python for socket programming but
there's very little documentation on
using Python to learn socket programming
and so with that distinction you can
understand like we can learn you know
what what Python code does what but what
does that actually mean and all of that
so it's kind of hard to get started
there also what little documentation we
have for Python and socket programming
it's written in Python too the problem
here is we come across one of the major
differences between Python 3 and Python
2 and that's the difference between bite
strings and strings so this becomes a
major issue when it comes to sockets
especially when it comes to singing and
receiving data and if we want to
actually like output that kind of data
so with that in mind let's go ahead and
start traversing sockets now it's going
to be kind of a decently sized made
series probably four or five six videos
deep but should be able to get through
at least the basics of sockets here so
without schoo head and get started so
first of all what the heck our sockets
okay so sockets are opening closed
basically to aid in the communication
between two entities and in most cases
you've got a server and a client and the
server quite literally serves
information to the client that's
requesting information when you visit a
web site you're opening up a socket and
you're you're requesting information
from a server which serves you data so
when you visit a web site you're you're
using a socket and then you're accessing
port right of the server and so the
server has generally port 80 open
if it's a website in any way and port 80
is used to transfer HTTP data and so
that's what a website does for example a
lot of websites are also going to have a
twenty port 20 open for like FTP access
which isn't very secure and then then
you have like a 22 which would be open
for SSH for example so anyway those are
just some quick examples also I mean
people have all kinds of ports like the
the lower numbered ports are all very
specific ports whereas the higher
numbered ports as you'll see later on we
can actually use that there's just
general purpose right so you can pretty
much use anything for them which gets
people in trouble later on down the road
when security is in question anyway
we'll get there so let's go ahead and
get started and getting down and dirty
with some sockets first of all to use
sockets we need to import socket socket
is a part of your standard library so
you don't have to install anything or
anything like that it is here the next
thing we want to do is look let's learn
how to specify a socket like how do we
create a socket so to do that you're
gonna say s equals socket dot socket and
then guess what comes next
socket dot and all caps AF underscore
eye net and what this means is you're
basically just you're saying what sort
of a connection that you want this to be
you don't really need to know exactly
what this is the other one is like gosh
it has like a P in it I want to say and
it's for like ipv4 traffic and stuff
like that but anyway moving along that's
basically just the connection type that
we want to use and then finally of
socket dot sock underscore stream and a
sock stream is what's going to allow us
to make a TCP connection whereas you
have other things like DeGraff instead
of sock stream sock d gram this would be
a UDP connection but we generally are
going to be using TCP for networking and
all that so we're going to go ahead and
stick with TCP the next thing that we
want we can actually go ahead and just
print out s and let's see what we what
we have at this point
I guess we'll wait a moment or something
here we go it's coming slow so here we
have the socket address we have our
address family the type of socket that
it is so does the information that we
pretty much just specified next with
this socket generally you want to
communicate with the socket so we're
going to communicate with the server and
it's going to be a remote server and the
server we're going to use is a Python
programming net so this is obviously my
website and we're going to try to
communicate with my website and then
later on we'll we'll do some other
things with it as well so next we
specify we know this is where we want to
communicate with next what we want to do
is we want to specify on what port do we
want to communicate with the server in
our case we're going to communicate on
port 80 so basically we're going to act
like a browser and access this on port
80 which is meant for HTTP so from here
we can do all sorts of things um we can
we can actually you can make a request
and connect to a server based on its IP
address or I mean it's it's planet it's
domain name but you can also use the
r.i.p address that's kind of the more
official way of doing things so if you
do want to get a server's IP address
what you can do is server underscore IP
equals socket get host by name and then
server conversely you could open up you
know command dot exe and you can just
ping Python programming net and you see
there okay well we've got our address
107 171 76 133 but this will also do it
for you as well so then and just to show
us that we did it a server IP is what
we'll print out and now we want to
actually make a request with this socket
so we're going to do request equals and
we're going to make a get request and
this get request is going to look funky
but it's an HTTP request
so in all caps we're going to say get
slash space space slash space HTTP slash
1.1
um this is going to be a backslash n for
like new line and then host : and space
+ server + and then two more new lines
new line new line and so that's um this
server up here so we're making this
request on Python program and I are now
using server IP here but a lot of people
will insist that you use server IP but
it does not matter next we're going to
say s equals socket dot socket oh
actually we were ready to find that so
we don't have to define that so now we
just need to do a connect so s dot
connect and then in here we connect a to
first of all I want to do Python
programming net and then on what port do
we want to connect to well we want to
connect on port well we'll just use port
I suppose or and I suppose we could also
pass through here server server port and
then from here the next thing we want to
do is we're going to say s dot send and
then we want to say the request dot and
code and here's a major difference
between what you'll see in Python 3
versus Python 2 is this encoding we
naturally want to use strings but
actually we're using byte strings so we
have to encode the stuff that we're
trying to send here because naturally it
is in the improper format in Python 2.7
you won't have this problem it's totally
a breeze but Python 3 correctly so makes
the distinction now we're going to say
results equals s dot RS see me and we're
going to use you can put you know like
1024 in here or whatever they recommend
anything between two and four thousand
so we're going to use four thousand on
the upper hand what is this this is your
buffer so how much data are we going to
be download at any given moment okay so
your buffer now when we're all done
let's just go ahead and print the result
and this won't be buffered but result
will be buffer we could instead print
the buffer well well we can't really do
that we would not need to make a little
loop for it we'll do that later for now
let's just let's run this and see where
we stand so save and run that and sure
enough we get all this gobbledygook
output but up at the top we get our
socket that we printed out the server IP
that we got and then begins our request
which as you can see it begins with a B
that means byte code so again the
request that we take in is going to be
byte code so then if we start trying to
manipulate it with strings we're going
to get ourselves in a little bit of
trouble so when you receive data you
have to decode it and before you send
the data you're going to have to encode
it that's the way it's going to be so
keep that in mind as we move on or if
you happen to maybe look at someone
else's code for an example that you're
looking for so anyway um the other thing
that we can do now that we've printed
our results is listen to comment out
that and let's make some more space here
and now let me show you buffering so
what we can do is we say wow Len result
is less than 0 so while there's still
something to come from the result we can
print result and then we can say results
equals s dot receive and then 4096 so we
can do that instead and we're not
printing this out anymore and then now
we can save and run this and we'll
actually try to move it fast enough but
if you watch it yourself you should be
able to see some buffering in there in
fact we can change this say 1024 and
then you can see how it kind of scrolled
it didn't all paste it all at the same
time that's buffering in action anyway
hopefully you can see it better yourself
for it hold that window down but yeah so
anyways that's it with the basics of
sockets again this is the first video in
a series of sockets so we'll get to be
doing a few more things so if you have
any questions or comments on what we've
covered so far I feel free to leave them
below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time